[Music]
your kids just went there well there you
got 11 year old five year old 2 year old
and an 8 month old so it's a lot of kids
and they you know my kids are starting
to you know it's nice now cuz they're
old enough now they can like write yeah
we've been doing that I want to be true
like they can get a book deal nice to
know it's like we told them to get a
packet together we'll submit it to set
free
yeah but you know you want to have an
active participation in your children's
life and so I'm always encouraging my
you know my five-year-old is is starting
to write and it's amazing the level of
sarcasm that you will see at such a
young age and my son he you know he
would write something and he would show
me and I and I and I took a picture of
one of the things that he wrote maybe we
can take a look at it here look at this
dad you are fat
oh you know but the thing is it's like
it's not like I'm not fat and you know
but it's I love the sarcasm and you know
so we've been working on it and so we
have made some improvement you've made
progress we've made some progress if we
can take a look at where is one of us
dad is fat he's doing much better first
of all it's gone from like a text
message to a complete sentence yeah yeah
and then let is led to the it's very
legible yeah it's good it's all caps
it's he's yelling it I'm impressed by it
uh I'm sure you're taking a lot of
photos lately you know it's it's I think
our whole culture we have to settle down
with the with the picture taking we take
pictures of everything and it's like
it's like we act like we're capturing
history unbelievable the cats taking a
nap let's take a picture it's it's
really it's because we have the cameras
on our phones do we need that it's not
as if ten years ago we were like I wish
I could take a low-quality photo of my
dessert
if only and we all these photos now it's
like I don't know what we're supposed to
do with them I mean it's set for make
our computers run slow it's I have more
pictures of my children than my father
ever looked at me I keep taking them you
know we used to have boxes of photos in
our closets now it's just old computers
yes you know it's like there's our
wedding computer there's my computer
when I was single I should probably
destroy that one now you you obviously
you have a lot of fans you have diehard
fans and they send you strange things
and I told that you you brought us some
photos I brought some photos you know
it's it's these are real and very
flattering I know it's it's it's
consistent on your show and and it's
some of them are inspired by jokes that
I used to have this joke a long time ago
this character of this Roscoe the wood
guy yeah and so after a show someone
brought me this and I just loved it and
it kind of started it's you carved in
wood yes and then what I love about this
is it's a it's correct proportion of the
size of head to body yes you and I have
Co obviously we did a cartoon
collaboration called pale for pal for
Ashley you it was you
I never still bitter you never gave me a
creative saying how I was depicted look
how you do it you decided how you're
depicted that's a pretty fair
representation yeah I mean I don't have
a beard you're right so but otherwise
that spot-on and of course pale force
was the idea of Paul Noth is a friend of
mine who's a cartoonist at The New
Yorker and but this is my favorite gift
that I've received from people that have
come to shows and I don't wanted to show
you this is from I received this I
believe in Kansas City and this is Munky
the sock monkey pail force this is if
you can hold that this is me this is you
then her she did also she did Conan
I think it's why am i wearing why am i
wearing ballet slippers she was trying
to put you up a little bit I think man
we are out of time